Hi, I’m Adriene Hill and Welcome to Crash
Course Statistics.
We’ve spent out a lot of time talking about
data visualization and different kinds of
frequency plots--like dot-plots and histograms--that
tell us how frequently things occur in data
we actually have.
But so far in this series, the data we have
talked about usually isn’t ALL the data
that exists.
If I want to know about student loan debt
in America, I am definitely not going to ask
over 300 million Americans.
I’m lazy like that.
But maybe I can find the time to ask 2,000
of them.
Samples...and the shapes they give us...are
shadows of what all the data would look like.
We collect samples because we think they’ll
give us a glimpse of the bigger picture.
They’ll tell us something about the shape
of all the data.
Because it turns out we can learn almost everything we need to know about data from its shape.
Intro
Picture a histogram of every single person’s
height.
Now imagine the bars getting thinner, and
thinner, and thinner ...as the bins get smaller
and smaller.
Till they are so thin that the outline of
our histogram looks like a smooth line ...since
this is a distribution of continuous numbers.
And there’s an infinite possibility of heights.
I am 1.67642… (and on and on) meters tall.
If we let our bars be infinitely small, we
get a smooth curve, also known as the distribution
of the data.
A distribution represents all possible values
for a set of data...and how often those values
occur.
Distributions can also be discrete.
Like the number of countries people have visited.
That means they only have a few set values--that
they can take on.
These distributions look a lot more like the
histograms we’re used to seeing.
Like a histogram, the distribution tells us
about the shape and spread of data.
We can think of distributions as a set of
instructions for a machine that generates
random numbers.
Let’s say it generates the number of leaves
on a tree.
You may well be wondering why we’d have
a tree-leaf-number generating machine.
The idea here is that EVERYTHING can generate
data.
It’s not just mechanical stuff.
It’s leaves and animals and even people.
The distribution is what specifies how the
knobs and dials on our machine are set.
Once the machine is set, every time there’s
a new tree, the machine pops out a random
number of leaves from the distribution.
It won’t be the same number each time though.
That’s because it’s a random selection
based on the information the knobs and dials
tell us about our distribution of leaves.
When we look at samples of data generated
by our leaf machine, we’re trying to guess
the shape of the distribution and how that
machine’s knobs and dials are set.
But remember, samples of data are not all
the data, so when we compare the shapes of
two samples of data, we’re really asking
whether the same distribution--these two machine
settings--could have produced these two different--but
sorta similar--shapes.
If you got an especially expensive electricity
bill last month, you may want to look at the
histogram of your average daily energy consumption
this month, and the same month last year side-by-side.
It’s not that realistic to expect that you
consumed energy at EXACTLY the same rate this
month as you did the year before.
There are probably some differences.
But your question is whether there’s enough
difference to conclude that your energy consuming
behaviors have changed.
When we think about data samples as being
just some of the data made using a certain
distribution shape, it helps us compare samples
in a more meaningful way.
Because we know that the samples approximate
some theoretical shape, we can draw connections
between the sample and the theoretical machine
that generated it, which is what we really
care about.
While data come in all sorts of shapes, let’s
take a look at a few of the most common, starting
with the normal distribution.
We mentioned the Normal distribution when
we talked about the different ways to measure
the center of data--since the mean, median,
and mode of a normal distribution are the
same.
This tells us that the distribution is symmetric,
meaning you could fold it in half and those
halves would be the same and that it’s unimodal,
meaning there’s only one peak.
The shape of a normal distribution is set
by two familiar statistics: the mean and standard
deviation.
The mean tells us where the center of the
distribution is.
The standard deviation tells us how thin or
squished the normal distribution is.
Since the standard deviation is the average
distance between any point and the mean, the
smaller it is the closer all the data will
be to the mean.
We’ll have a skinnier normal distribution.
Most of the data in the normal distribution--about
68%--is within 1 standard deviation of the
mean on either side.
Just like the quartiles in a boxplot, the
smaller the range that 68% of the data has
to occupy, the more squished it gets.
Speaking of boxplots here’s what the boxplot
for normally distributed data looks like.
The two halves of our box are exactly the
same because the normal distribution is symmetric.
You’ve probably seen the normal distribution
in a lot of different places, it gets called
a Bell Curve sometimes.
Attributes like IQ and the number of Fruit
Loops you get in a box are approximately normally
distributed.
Normal distributions come up a lot when we
look at groups of things, like the total value
rolled after 10 dice rolls, or birth weights.
We’ll talk more about why the normal distribution
is so useful in the future.
As we’ve seen in this series, data isn’t
always normal or symmetric, often times it
has some extreme values on one side making
it a little bit skewed.
Age at death during the middle ages is left-skewed...cause lots of people died young while the time it
takes to fill out the Nerdfighteria survey
was right skewed because some people lolly-gagged.
In a boxplot of data from a skewed distribution,
the median will not usually split the box
into two even pieces.
Instead the side with the skewed tail will
tend to be stretched out, and often, we’ll
see a lot of outliers on that side, just like
the boxplot of the Nerdfighteria survey times.
When we see those features in our sample of
data, it suggests that the distribution that
generated our data also has some kind of skewed
tail.
Skew can be a useful way to compare data.
For example, teachers often look at the distribution
of scores on a test to see how difficult the
test was.
Really difficult tests tend to generate skewed scores, with most students doing pretty poorly
and a few who still ace it.
Say we flashed pictures of 20 pokemon and
asked people to name them.
Here are their grades.
Or another sample from a test asking people
to list all 195 countries.
We can compare the shapes and centers of these
two groups of tests, as well as any other
notable features.
First of all, these two samples look pretty
similar.
Both have a right skew.
Both have a pretty low center, but the second
test has a more extreme skew.
Bigger skewed tails usually mean that the
data--and therefore the distribution--has
both a larger range, and a bigger standard
deviation than data with a smaller tail.
The standard deviation is higher because not
only are extreme data further away from the
mean, they drag the mean toward them, making
most of the other points just a little further
from the mean too.
While the direction of the skew tells you
where most of the data is--always on the opposite
side of the skewed tail--the extremeness of
the skew can help you mentally compare the
approximate measures of spread, like range
and standard deviation.
But we compare the shapes of two samples in
order to ask whether the shape of the distributions
that generated them are different, or whether
ONE shape could have randomly created both
samples.
In terms of our machine analogy, we ask whether
one machine with its knob settings could have
spit out two sets of scores, one that looks
like test A, and one that looks like test
B. Answering that question get’s complicated,
but we’ll get there.
Now that we’ve examined the tails, let’s
look at the middle of some distributions.
Almost all the distributions we’ve seen
so far are unimodal--they only have one peak.
But there’s many times when data might have
two or more peaks.
We call it bimodal or multimodal data.
And it looks like the back of a camel, or
maybe like two of our unimodal distributions
pasted side by side.
And, that’s probably what’s happening--the
unimodal distributions, not the camel thing.
Often when you see multimodal data in the
world it’s because there are two different
machines with two different distributions
that are both generating data that is being--for
some reason or other--measured together.
One possible example of this is the length
in minutes that the geyser Old Faithful erupts.
Most eruptions last either about 2 minutes,
or about 4 minutes, with few eruptions around
the 3-minute mark, giving us a bimodal distribution.
It’s entirely possible that there are two
different mechanisms behind the data, even
though they’re being measured together.
For example, one set of conditions may lead
to an eruption that’s about 2 minutes long,
and another--maybe a different temperature
or latency--leads to a different kind of eruption
which lasts on average 4 minutes.
Since these two potentially different types
of eruptions are being measured together,
the data look like they come from one distribution
with two bumps, but it is likely that there’s
two unimodal distributions being measured
at the same time.
Another example that you don’t need to be
a geologist to understand is the race times
for some marathons.
While this data may look like it comes from
a unimodal distribution, in reality there’s
two big groups of people who run a marathon:
those that are competing, and those that do
it to prove they can do it.
There’s usually one peak around the time
that all the professional runners cross the
finish line, and another when the amateurs do.
While we don’t know for sure that bimodal
data is secretly two distributions disguised
as one, it is a good reason to look at things
more closely.
We’ll finish today with uniform distribution.
Even though we haven’t mentioned uniform
distributions yet, you’ve probably come
across them in your everyday life.
Each value in a uniform distribution has the
same frequency, just like each number on a
die has exactly the same chance of being rolled.
When you need to decide something fairly,
like which of your 6 roomates has to do dishes
tonight, or which friend to take to the Jay-Z
concert--the best thing you can do is use
something--like a die--that has a uniform
distribution.
That gives everyone an equal chance of being
picked.
And you can have uniform distributions with
any number of outcomes.
There are 20-sided dice.
When you’re in Vegas playing a round of
roulette the ball is equally likely to land
in any of 38 slots.
There’s a difference between the shape of
all the data, and the shape of a sample of
the data.
When we talk about a uniform distribution,
we’re talking about the settings of that
data generating machine, it doesn’t mean
that every sample--or even most samples--
of our data will have exactly the same frequency
for each outcome.
It’s entirely possible that rolling a die
60 times results in a sample shaped like this:
Even if we know the theoretical distribution
looks like this:
Using statistics allow us to take the shape
of samples that has some randomness and uncertainty,
and make a guess about the true distribution
that created that sample of data.
Statistics is all about making decisions when
we’re not sure.
It allows us to look at the shape of 60 dice
rolls and figure out whether we believe the
die is fair... or whether the die is loaded
or whether we need to keep rolling.
Whether it’s finding the true distribution
of eruption times at Old Faithful, or showing
evidence that a company is discriminating
based on age, gender, or race.
The shape of data gives us a glimpse into
the true nature
of what is happening in the world.
Thanks for watching and DFTBAQ.
I’ll see you next time.